it is the time where I was turning
underwear inside out over and over again
for us to think that was going to not
make us stinky girls walking around in
the world wait you used to of side a
side B when you you know when you're in
New York for the summer and you're 21 or
whatever and or 19 yeah you don't know
laundry New York is hard laundry in New
York is a whole thing you can wash
underwear at
19 slugs I'm so excited drugstore June
is in theaters we just added a new city
so March 1st Austin and tickets are on
sale now so you can get tickets
currently at drugstore june. comom to
see us February 23rd that is when we
open in New York and la and then Austin
and we're adding new cities all the time
so just check out our website thank you
for buying tickets and supporting this
Indie and I can't wait for you guys to
have a fun in theater experience with a
bunch of comics on the screen that you
recognize including me sluggy I am on
the road I'm having so much fun I'm
getting ready for my special so so my
set is tight it's good I'm really
working on it so I'm excited to show it
to you my next Road gig is in one of my
favorite places Denver Colorado at The
Comedy Works February 16th and 17th my
next Annie wood in France is February
20th at the comedy store then I'll be in
Vancouver for the Just for Laughs Comedy
Festival February 21st and 22nd I'm
going to be in Fort Worth Texas March
1st and second and then I am extremely
excited to be going to New Mexico for
the first time ever since I moved out of
there
I'm going to Albuquerque I'll be there
the 8th and 9th it's going to be so wild
I'm going to be uh in Washington DC at
the end of March and then I'll be in
Jacksonville Florida rescheduled for the
end of June dates are always being added
so go to Annie letter.com show guys
what's going on in trash Tuesday news
tell me well um February 13th there's a
lot to talk about uh because we're
having our second live show and that's
where we spill the tea and it's gonna be
in La it's in Los Angeles it's going to
be Valentine's Day
themed come with a date come Alone come
with your girlies maybe you'll leave on
the date oh that's a really good point
maybe we should play
Cupid wait okay we're doing excited we
set K
up you guys get tickets at the link
below we will see you in La February
13th we are so excited for this live
show these don't happen often so get
your tickets now and we'll see you
there my family that visited from the
Philippines I don't know one of their
suitcases broke so I sent them off back
to the
Philippines right there she captured
them um back with like my favorite aroan
bag and they don't know what the [__]
arowana is and I kept having to tell
them hey like this is a
very yeah like this is status and
they're like are you ready I don't think
you're ready for this jelly but my niece
understood the value of the Traer Joe's
one but not the A1 one it hasn't caught
on yet over there it's too nich yeah
it's too niche but Trader Joe's like
everyone knows about America core and
they want to make fun of us by
cosplaying as us do you think they're
cosplaying or they actually like it like
I don't know like but there is like a I
do find it really I mean obviously like
I'm not the group to be offended by this
so it's not for me to speak on but I
like it when Asian people take it too
far with like the cholo culture or like
things of like like Western subcultures
that they completely step into and they
like I I don't know if you've ever seen
like the cholos in Asia so these are the
Bangkok cholos so those are the Bangkok
Mexican gangsters is what they're and um
they learn the lingo they say things
like do they say like Fe but I see these
guys in the Philippines too but we just
have a different term for them I just
like these two guys because the one guy
before this has like my wide head
problem where his sunglasses are too
small for his head and then the other
guy like could be wearing the same
sunglasses and they're like too big for
his head it's like us yeah have you guys
heard of the this concept called pacing
your pleasures throughout the day
basically I saw this guy talking about
this and it I it totally like rang true
for me he was saying that in your 20s
it's very common that you will place all
your pleasures in the first part of your
day or the last part of your like people
will wake up they'll have their coffee
they'll get high they'll do whatever
feels good and then the rest of the day
it's like it's just kind of going
downhill or they'll be like I have to
suffer through the whole day with no
pleasures and then at night you know you
weed you're drinking whatever and he's
like the secret to adulthood is being a
functioning drug ad you just do it
throughout the day a little bit every
day just a little snort every few
minutes it's great 100% but I was like
wait I need to make sure that I'm pacing
my Pleasures because I am just unhappy
all day and I want to let I feel like I
have a chance now what are your
pleasures what's the I have none left
but what okay if you were to be like
okay if there was if if a million
dollars fell right here oh you wouldn't
spend a penny of it you wouldn't spend a
penny of if it was someone else's money
and you had to spend it and it was just
for it wasn't it couldn't be
work-related couldn't be anything like
what would unless work-related would be
your pleasure if it was like all right
tomorrow from noon to the problem no the
it's just I would want to get high and
eat chocolate Okay so without the baby
if this is a without the baby I don't
know this is you tell me you guys tell
me a million dollars and had to spend it
and I had to make a decision yourself
you don't have to spend all of it but
like you could just do anything you want
I the rules are you can't put it in your
mutual funds you can't invest would be
fun what if investing it would be
fun I think I think you enjoy a little
suffering you would like a little
suffering while the money just sits and
you're like one day that's really not
pacing your pleasure your pleasure is
for like the day after you die you're
like the day after I die I'm going have
the most beautiful funeral but you
wouldn't you wouldn't would just be
sitting sha no it's going to be a very
low-key funer funeral cuz my dad always
talks about how like the funeral homes
they upsell you always and then you're
in your most vulnerable place he's like
my he's like I buried my mom in a
Cherrywood casket I should dig it up
talking about as you're dressed like
Wednesday Adams wait but this is so true
Wednesday Adams I'll tell you that I I
was laughing with my mom yesterday cuz I
was like hey remember when we brought
Papa's ashes back home in like a Von
plastic bag and she was like that wasn't
a Von's plastic bag I paid $900 tra
Joe's tote okay how expensive they are
she was like it I paid n we paid $900 I
was like for what it was like a burlap
sack they get you and they get you
because you are in a moment of grief and
you're like are you sure you don't want
to take this for your loved one and
there is that Cherrywood right there and
it's like
$3500 or you could be like you know yeah
I'll pay $900 for that Von plastic bag
it's it's a you're so skewed in the head
in in that time you do anything to like
commemorate this person you're missing I
also just started watching 6 feet under
which is all about funeral such a great
such you guys have seen it are you
kidding it's like my gay Awakening eser
oh my God you guys it's so good why
didn't you tell me don't you love um how
is so good it's so weird and random talk
about this guy the guy yes he he was
yeah he was that is he the hot one he's
the T really tall darkhaired one who
dates the sister the Dre girl oh I don't
think I've met him yet no you're not
there no maybe you're not there
you guys watching show premium cable
content from
2001 is like the that takes place in La
it reminds me almost of the LW like
early 2000's La based premium cable
shows are just hitting me in all the
right areas they're so comforting and
make me sad about how this that TV is
not a thing anymore this no that that La
sucks now it's too hot here well you
know what's actually fun to even watch
as like La story if you go to like 80s
like early 90s 90 s Steve Martin I don't
remember what year they came out but
it's like it's like old school it's
really fun wait what would you guys
spend the money on okay so the rules are
cannot invest can't do anything like
smart an adult like it has to be a big
Splurge I would this is such an Annie
question I get a boat I would get a boat
and that would be like I would feel so
good you only get it for one day though
[__] I'd feel so sad yeah it be sad to
watch it go really would wait hold on a
second I don't get to would you rent
like a great yacht or something yeah I
would blow it all in a really I had a
crazy I want to come back to this
because I haven't answered yet but I had
a crazy thought the other day about you
Kila I was like I've never asked her one
question about diving she just goes 40
feet underwater it's I don't want to
it's like I and we she'll just bring it
up and we're like anyway um like she
just has a weird there's a life that she
has that's so weird like like I want to
know what's like a day in the life of
kalila diving A Day in the Life is um I
wake up maybe at 5 5:30 in the morning
let's say I am not here I'm in a warmer
place yeah and I pack all my dive gear
my wet suit my fins my mask my dive
knife my spear guns um do you use the
knife yeah because when I when I shoot
the fish and it's still um um I have to
I didn't want to know about this fish
yeah you spear it like it's I spear it
with a spear gun I take the fish and I
brain it I have to kill it because when
a fish is in distress it's actually I
need you to be sit in the discomfort cuz
I have to hear every who are you really
it's a dinner bell sharks it's very
normal and very common nine out of my 10
Dives like I will encounter like a shark
and they're usually just cruising they
like mind their own business but they
will always come usually what if they're
not in the usual mood I've never other
than like one time really come across
like a a a shark that was not even going
for me it was going after the fish that
I had I think their point is that one
time is enough no but I love it I'm like
this sounds right up my alley no but I
it's it's so weird because I think that
like leading up to the point where I
actually was was Swimming with Sharks I
was afraid and then you're in the ocean
and then you actually see them and
you're like oh it's fine yes but why is
it fine why are we because they really
are just cruising for the most part like
not to say that like shark stuff doesn't
happen it really does and you have to be
careful when you have like a bloody fish
on you and you smell like fish um but
for the most part like I would say like
that's not my biggest fear going into
the water there's so many other things
that could kill me when I spear fish
like getting tangled up in my own line
or like like drowning or like shallow
water blackouts there's so many other
dangerous things that could happen
versus like a shark are you worried
about the bz the bz happens more with
scuba diving but because I I free dive
and I'm going on my own breath it's it's
like hardly that could ever happen and
plus I'm not diving like these free
divers who go like 200 feet below like
did you ever watch the story about the
girl that I did wait not M worried about
you I was like oh my God someone's gonna
kill her while she's down there no no no
no no I'm so the fifth scariest thing is
a shark you're saying when you or like
it's lower I I would say like any spear
fisherman um it's it's it's like they
you swim with them so much and they're
always there that they're they're just
not like a a thing that you get spooked
about in the water your heart race if
you see a shark not really anymore if I
were to see like like that they were
posturing in a certain you have to punch
it right isn't that the move no I have a
spear gun in front of me so unless
they're coming behind me you always you
can poke them a little bit you could
hurt it with your yeah but I've never HT
a shark that way I've poked the shark
like coming towards so if I'm swimming
in the ocean we can't imagine this this
is actually already an impossible scenar
I'm telling a story The Shark could save
you the shark could actually save you
lift you up to the top cuz you're
drowning if you're in the ocean it's not
a good sign let's just say I'm swimming
and I see we're going to you're not
pregnant we're keeping a baby out of
this St yes I can be regular me and I
see a fin with I see the thing
triangle sticking out of the water and
it's and so you're saying like just
chill it's not going to come try to hurt
me know seen in every movie you're
describing a fear of mine which is not
having a mask on and swimming in an
ocean where I cannot see what's under me
that's like a legitimate fear of mine
when I have a mask on and I'm I'm fully
suited up and I have a gun in my hand no
like that doesn't seem as scary but if
I'm just floating around and don't know
what underneath me like I'm spooked yeah
okay yeah so that's a normal feeling I'm
having another tangent thought I want to
go back to that and then go back to the
other thing but you saying like not
wearing the things that being blurry not
being able to see what it is I'm having
a flashback to one of my favorite movies
adventures and babysitting did you see
that movie I never saw okay there's a
scene where there's a girl at um this
girl's friend I she's trying to get back
to Elizabeth Shu the main character
she's like trapped at the bus station or
something she can't find her glasses her
glasses are gone and she thinks think
there's like a dog or a cat and she goes
to like she's like oh and it's like a
big rat and I think about that a lot
it's a big scene for my life and then
when I was on vacation I didn't go with
my nieces and nephews to they went to a
arcade and my baby niece you know they
you win like stuffed animals and stuff
so there was this what she thought was a
stuffed animal on the ground and she yes
operation don't let this become a core
memory is like we've all been trying but
so she went to like she was like what's
this and she picked it up and she was
like there was blood on it it was just
like a
dead rat like big giant rat what did you
guys do well I wasn't there but her mom
was like put it down and then and then
it was like the rest of the time was
like haha isn't that so funny that we
all just had to like that's the funniest
thing ha Claire isn't that so funny to
just try to put it in her head as like a
funny memory so she doesn't realize that
what she did was think she was touching
a sweet safe beautiful stuffed animal
instead it was a dead poison probably
this why laughing at sad horrible times
is only option yes I mean that's one
that's one of the reasons why that one
scene in Dumb and Dumber where he where
the kid the blind kid is petting the
dead bird is one of the funniest things
like ever right cuz they don't know the
innocence of it yeah the innocence and
like the the the bird's head was like
stapled back or taped back on or
something like that it's up but it it is
it's sad and funny okay rat just while
we're on
rat it's gonna be one of those I'm on
Aderall today and it's not it's doing
the
opposite when I was like doing a summer
in New York in college to like do a
dance program and we were living in
student housing I one night like heard
this like rattling of like around my
food and I I had this like case of odd
Wala bars and I woke up the next morning
and like all of them were opened and
eaten and I was so upset and I slept did
you accuse someone with that did it no
cuz it was just me in the room cuz I had
an issue with my roommate I had to be
relocated they kept munching on your s
they were like your underwear was all
chewed up like what the hell are you
doing it is the time where I was turning
underwear inside out over and over again
is this um for us to think that was
going to not make us stinky girls
walking around in the world wait you
used to of side a side B when you you
know when you're in New York for the
summer and you're 21 or whatever and or
19 yeah you don't know La in New York is
hard laundry in New York is a whole wash
underwear at 19 okay so my whole life I
was like shamed for one time doing a
side a side B and who did you tell that
and I was like eight years old when I
did this my mom was like like mortified
like as if I was like the dirtiest thing
ever but honestly it makes sense for
some days of the month where you don't
have like a whole lot of like discharge
and stuff I think side a side B is very
environmental I don't really have those
days I don't want to be like crusty
[__] girl but I it I'm always there's
always dis charge interesting I never
wanted to approach this topic with you
guys but since we're here discharge
typically right now you're snailing
third trimester pregnancy you're
changing your underwear a few times a
day let's call it can we call it a slug
Trail when we talked about it on this
part or maybe it's more like a slush now
it's like a it's like a gloop gloop
there's okay so there's a thing about
pregnancy and birth that's a ter and it
just I think about it a lot it makes me
very uncomfortable I think I need to say
it to get it out oh God the term mucus
plug is really it's just an
upsetting there's certain things that I
tune out and that is absolutely it's
Kila spear fishing and the word mucus PL
and we'll probably get to a couple more
today but I also like feel like do you
remember on Live Throwing Copper when
they said her placenta falls to the
floor no on what on Liv's album Throwing
Copper Lightning Crashes yeah her
placenta falls to the floor the is that
guy crazy to like but it's so crazy to
just throw the word placent in it's just
song about uh it's like about abortions
and it's like okay will you pop the
lyrics real quick of honestly the
thought about placenta also Throwing
Copper live live um Lightning Crashes
okay so the lyrics go like this
Lightning Crashes a new mother cries her
placenta falls to the floor third line
third line to thr placenta the angel
opens her eyes the confusion sets in
before the doctor can even close the
door Lightning Crashes and old mother
dies it's the cycle of Life the 9 is a
lot about the cycle of life is it just
like it's life and death look an old
mother dies her intentions fall the
floor the angel closes her eyes so then
she's dying okay now the confusion that
was hers belongs to the baby down the
hall so now the old lady's going into
the young baby no and this is the mother
of the child that was just born who dies
this is an old mother this is an old
mother no this is an old mother no I
don't think so I think Annie's right
this is another it's a cycle circle of
life but maybe we should call him and
have him explain what kind of dark
what's the guy's name the live singer
who knows it was a the ball guy guy yeah
but I you know speaking of placenta
falling on the floor when I was present
for my best friend's birth her placenta
like didn't it wasn't like a a slow
birthing of it it shot out and honestly
like there was a thud on the ground
placenta thud slapped into the wall and
we were all like ah like we all like
step back but her she shot out her
placenta it was incredible oh like you
would think that when you get far along
in pregnancy that you suddenly become
comfortable with these ideas and you
just don't you just don't get
comfortable I think what happens from
what I've heard is
you basically it's a traumatic event
obviously very loving with a very
wonderful ending um and then you kind of
black it out a little yeah no one the
high of it I also was thinking oh it's
like a bikini wax like it hurts so much
and then afterwards you're like like
you're a little high yeah it's like a
bikini wax it's just like a bikini wa I
I haven't next week is my appointment
where we go over like how it's what's
the birth the plan yeah like if what
she's is she going to recommend a
C-section is she not like so do you have
like a loose idea in your mind or are
you just going to be open to all options
say loose I just want my ideal would be
if she just had like if she could just
look at everything and be like I
strongly recommend this so that the
decision making is really not up to me
because the amount of strong feelings
that are so different out there that
it's like political it is crazy out
there like the people who are extremely
Pro being induced extremely anti- being
induced Pro C-section anti like you
don't you say the wrong thing and you're
out forever it's like our culture now
it's so annoying it is everyone's got a
business the moms who are very like like
Pro home birth and pro anti meds anti-
epidural and it's like hey dude like you
can decide that for your body but like
maybe not just like you know be so
Evangelical about it and like force
other women to like or make other women
feel bad if that's not their decision I
think like if you're like a scientist or
something and this is your research and
stuff like that's cool to like put out
what you've learned or what you think is
like best or whatever but it's it's just
weird when it's like people are just
like having their own experience given
there and they're so yeah it's so weird
preachy or like it has to be this way I
will say though shout out to Michelle
wolf she did this whole piece on The
Daily Show that's on YouTube about how
she gave a home birth which I am not
interested in at all but respect I loved
all the research you presented and like
there's a lot of shadiness with
hospitals and birth I get it that's
still the route I'm taking but it was
like oh she's presenting a well
researched like other side of things and
I think if people are interested like
it's worth watching but the idea of you
not having a doctor present is so
psychotic it's just not for you it's not
for you I'm going to be covered in
nurses nurses will be touching every
part of my body you're going to pay
extra for more extra nurses I don't want
any Skin showing I want all nurses
covering me um what would you spend a
million dollars on you whack job I'm I
need to know this I would spend it on I
feel like you'd be at a shooting range
if I give it definitely shooting range
uh I spend it all on guns your own
semi-automatic guns no I would
definitely do like a private jet
somewhere but a short flight I'd do a
short flight to maybe like an island
maybe rent a yacht you calina Island it
takes 30 seconds it would be a very fast
one but you would fly private on your
millionaire day I'd fly somewhere short
private I would it's basically how much
can I damage the Earth in one I would
want to go see something special I would
want you know I've really been craving
to go to Antarctica so maybe I would fly
private to another flight and then fly
to Antarctica that sounds really really
fun my I want to do something like
that's crazy Cara's our our friend Cara
the yoga teacher her mom is on her way
to Antarctica like right now I like
these women this is what okay so my
sister-in-law's mom is like this where
they just like her and her sisters will
just go on trips and they just go to
Crazy places and I think when you've
like worked really hard and you retire
and you have this like leftover money
you're like I want to experience the
world and my sister-in-law's dad had
passed away so she's just kind of this
like lady that has some money and she's
just like spending the last of her like
going on these trips with her sisters
and I think it's cool so I think I I
would pay for like weird experiences you
know what I've always wanted to do huge
bucket list and I wonder if I ever will
do it I've always wanted to fly to Paris
like arrive around noon go to lunch go
to the French Pharmacy load up on
skincare and then literally just go back
home like I want to do like 3 hours in
Paris I've been watching a Morning Show
okay and she does she goes to fly to
like see Steve Carell you know Morning
Show with Jennifer Anderson yeah I I
don't watch it but so she like Steve
Carell gets like cancelled he's like
he's like the Matt low of the show okay
and then she was his co-host so she like
goes to like she needs to talk to him
he's like gone off to like Italy or
something and she flies there just to
like see him for a second and then Co
happens and she's like having all this
trouble leaving she like can't get a
flight and stuff so but I think that
people do that like really rich guys
like set up dates like that where you're
like hey let's go to Paris for
just to like treat a 12h hour
international flight like it's just
nothing to you there's something about
that there's power to that you're right
because it is it's nothing if you have a
life flat if you can Life Flat yeah I
mean such a game changer and having a
full comforter and it's like it's no
different you can get some Wi-Fi even
you can really just get your day done I
don't know something though are you guys
saying you're in or what I'm down do
they they fly to Europe in private jets
yes that's so crazy are there sugar
daddies for um for pregnant women I
don't know but when you find any let me
know I know a lot of people by the way
Esther who are like men my guy friends
who are like Esther's the hottest person
in the world like right now pregnancy
K with the pregnancy yeah that's so
weird the pregnant it's I really think
men it's there's two camps it's either
like they're disgusted by it or it just
does it for them well I think the
Madonna wh guys think it's gross and
then regular guys are like it's hot
she's like here she's like a woman doing
what she's supposed to do talk about I
think it's just biological maybe I don't
know but it's just something about it
she's like she's so sexy my womb is full
like you have no use for me biologically
but you're receptical they imagine they
imagine [__] in you it is a it's a
tough it's a tough it's a tough one to
take for a shy girl like you your shoes
could be for your daughter honestly
could literally be for your child this
is what I would get you for your baby
shower by the way this is a child this
is a baby toddler shoes the fact that
Kila just equated pregnancy to being a
[__] receptical I'm not I to save you I
tried to save you I tried to save you
but there is an extra component or an
extra layer about you which is like you
you look like a teenager you let someone
bust in you're a teenager that let
someone bust in good lighting for sure
in bad lighting it's a whole different
story I'm not it's it's I'm not perfect
no but you know what you're you know
what your worst scenarios you look a few
years younger than you are you don't
look like a small child you have two
options you either look like a very tiny
small young child or you look a little
younger than your actual age well I
stand by mentally having the teen
pregnancy physically geriatric and I am
the first yeah I think um but I think
that's the kind of pregnancy you guys
would have to I think the second kid
you're not as much of a teen but you got
to be a teen the first time's got to be
insane you're implying that I'm going to
have a second kid evil [__] the Royal
you I have rude [__] I listen I think
the [__] recepticle shuts I think there's
going to be a sewing up of where the [__]
can go and I don't think that's a thing
but we have a few are these fan
questions this one's a really good one
so this girl writes my boyfriend or it
could be a guy my boyfriend won't come
surfing with me because I'm better than
him and it's emasculating red flag yes I
have a I have a differing opinion here
what I'm I'm stumped you'd have the egg
for being worse than you I will never
set myself up to get the ick so I'm not
going to invite him to something I know
he's going to like possibly fail in um
just did an open micer oh yes it's the
same so basically it's like this like G
why would you again why would you even
say that sentence you're making me
sick it's like uh swimming say for
instance if a for me because I I spend a
lot of my time in the water if a guy
doesn't know how to swim if I see he's
health helpless it's it's immediately
like an ick for me right now if he was a
guy it's so funny that you would look at
him as helpless like is he drowning yeah
it's to me it's like like you can't
that's so sad it's true like I totally
know what you're saying but like if you
like took a guy out and he like almost
drowned and you'd be like have to break
up with him after his I would absolutely
have to I'd be like hey let's be friends
like this is your last kiss is the
CPR it's the last time you stick stick
your tongue in cuz this is the last one
I know what you mean like yeah and but
on top of that even like furthermore if
it was a guy who knew how to swim but
thought that he was good and then I see
him in the water and there is a you know
he's still struggling a little bit like
it would be an Nick so no like I think
it's do you need them to be able to do
like flip turns like Olympic flip turns
I need them to have just a good like I I
need them to be able to um not even do
laps but to float comfortably right if
the shark's coming for you yeah in fact
um I
I just like guys who know how to swim
really well that's always been my thing
like I I've never been in a relationship
with a guy who has doesn't like isn't
like a great swimmer I think that makes
sense like swimming is such a huge part
of your life it just can Bobby swim
really well really oh my God sense it
does make sense I don't know why great
and he SW he's like a turtle like
flipped over my God like the front was
that and he did the shark Dives with me
he's done two shark Dives he's done one
in South Africa with the great whites
and he did one with me with um a couple
like sand I want to ask more I would
also I'm down if you ever want to invite
me but um I Esther can film she'll be
holding the
camera she'll have Dave doing paparazzi
pics of us yeah so okay I want to go
back to the day in the life so you wake
up like 5:30 5 5:30 yeah you get all
your stuff m is the boat rented or is
this one of your friends boat most of
the time like it's a luxury to that's
why I'm saying I would get a boat it's a
luxury to have a boat and to take a boat
out and and and go hunting in the middle
of the ocean where there isn't like the
shore break but for the most part I dive
off the shore so I find a beach no no I
find a beach I swim out and I find a
fish pile and I dive maybe five pile
what's a fish pile fish pile is just you
start to see like you start to learn
like like fish Behavior fish movement
where the good fish are and you sort of
a fish pile is just where you see like a
bunch of different fish I'm just Trigg
cuz that's what my they call you they
called me when I was lost my virginity
and so and then I'm out there for five
six hours if it's like a good day and
I'm diving I'm just shooting fish
shooting fish putting it on my line Sho
and you're with other people you can't
always with a dive buddy right and then
so you just put them on a line and you
can just like you just bring them along
with you you drag them along yeah and
then we go back to Shore and then when
you get back to store you scale the fish
and then you um gut the fish and then
you take it home you um put it in a look
at Esther's eyes just GL well just
you're so lucky that you have a hobby
and that it takes up like the whole day
like I that's not common I think but I
think you have a passion and it's
physically active and it's like you're
it's within nature like this is the key
that's the whole secret to a happy you
guys realize when I got good at this
right like I was always just dabbling
before but when Bobby and I broke up
like I had nowhere to go I was so
terrified of existing on land I was so I
was pelted by like so much just like
internet like vitrio like I was really
in a would you say you were getting shot
with a with a I was getting spear
spear yeah I was getting speared on land
and like the water was the only place
where like I was able to sort of like
feel safe and feel held and I couldn't
hear the noise and that's where I kind
of like retreated to right and so like
so much of what I'm able to do now
really only happened in the last like 2
and a half years because like I as corny
as it sounds like I had nowhere else to
go that is so cool and inspiring and I
feel like that's always this the case
it's like you go through something so
horrible and then that's the time where
your brain is like I have to like obsess
breakups are literally number one it
makes you live in the moment I did that
with snowboarding I've been going on
solo trips like after a hard breakup and
it's been awesome like it makes you
really live in the moment and be like
it's the
don't matter and H a skill and like it's
it's such a relief to fixate on
something that is so worlds apart from
the stuff that's hurting you and you're
like oh no one can hurt me here like any
one of these internet trolls I would
drown I would absolutely murder in these
waters you know what I mean like there
is like a feeling of like I'm so safe
here even with sharks even with the
threat of being Tangled Up in a line and
like doing it all wrong and drowning but
I just felt like like oh like this this
like place this like water has my back
you had nowhere else to turn yeah and it
felt really good and it's so meditative
CU you're dropping to the bottom of the
ocean on one breath and it's like you
have to be very present would you guys
consider long walks having owned a skill
or no just be honest I think so I think
when walking seems so difficult for the
person when it seems like walking isn't
really their thing where it's more of
like this red Wadd the fact that you
honestly walk less pregnant now is the
weird thing because I've heard that that
waddle is like it only exacerbates the
pain so you have to like force yourself
not to do the little the Esther waddle
the I mean it's it's a swad waddle I've
had pregnancy pain my whole life it's my
I've had a loose SI the idea that you
wouldn't go to a hospital when you're
actually supposed to be there is so
funny like it's a dream for you yeah I
don't I mean it's not a dream because
it's but Dave keeps saying that he's
like you love nurses you love the way
you love the Hospital you love the way
they take care of you and it's true I I
love nurses are you listening to things
when you walk or is it total silence no
especially while pregnant no I'm not and
because I'm trying
because there's so much time in the day
where you're just a little bit
uncomfortable I'm trying to separate all
my Pleasures so it's like I don't eat a
meal while I watch TV anymore at least
for right now you know I'm trying I got
to spread it out
very Japanese of you too I think right
so I when I walk I don't listen to
something you know I just I'm spreading
it out which is a little I know that's
like a little sad because listening to
something while walking and eating while
watching TV those are the best best
moments of life but you can are you
thinking a lot that when you're walking
or are you trying to be like meditative
and have a clear a lot of the times I'm
like hamstring but hamstring but because
I'm I'm trying to activate those things
so that my back won't hurt good that's
good then you're having like a like a
meditative walk hamstring butt
accidentally hamstring but well that's
good because it's like Breathe In
Breathe Out breathe in breathe out wait
can you explain hamstring butt because
if I don't actively work on making sure
those leg butt muscles are activating it
just will weirdly sink into my back and
my lower back will do the work it has
something to do with having a loose SI
joint I think oh no she had summoned
give her is that your sacr alal yeah and
like you
my whole thing now is I am carrying all
this extra weight you're going to like
get in bad postures and you're going to
hurt yourself so I'm just I keep
thinking to myself more is coming more
weight is coming like I need to build up
these legs to hold this up and that's
like been my whole thing the last couple
and I just like attach like little
stilts like you know what I mean when
they when you break a toe and you um no
I'm not ready to go back to that that
was actually more than this it was that
was a lot more broken toe was broken
pinky toe was harder than I know it is
bad it's just so funny like I know
breaking a toe is really painful but
it's so funny that was your I didn't
know that for you to have the
littlest injury is so funny Sal I broke
this finger catching like a shitty
football pass and I didn't know it was
broken for months and I was like kept
telling myself I was like oh it's just
the sprain it's just a sprain so every
day I would take this broken finger and
I would yank
and stretch it out I it need like the
blood flow and I would Shake It by the
time I got an x-ray my doctor was like
oh like you have like 67,000
fragments bone everywhere so I needed to
get um surgery on this hand and like a
[__] pin put for like a long time but
that's how stupid I am so I'm glad you
took your toe injury seriously cuz I did
not do it with this hand and I caused
myself a lot more damage by trying to
like you know that is so crazy so stupid
yeah and it hurt so bad when I did it
it's not like I was like not feeling the
pain but I was just like it's just the
sprain cuz I was in denial have you ever
like dislocated a shoulder and put it
back in never dislocated but um have you
uh-uh that seems like I don't think I
would I would not do it myself I would
be afraid I was doing the wrong thing I
don't believe that those that's real
when when I see that like that is wild
that you can literally dislocate
something and then have it shove that
was in the movie The holdovers the kid
had that and it's just like that can't
be right I think it's because it happens
a lot to people who have this locy
shoulders so they're used to the whole
they've seen someone do it or some
people are just
like Show Must Go On do you know what I
mean those people they're just like
you're kind of like that not really
though now I'm really learning to not
just um uh what do you call it like
toughen up this is an Asian
appropriating Hispanic culture oh yeah
this is um um instead of banana break
today I have um brought my own just
Coconut and Mango with um lime chamoy
and tahin yum is that for the street
vendors without got that at my wedding
and it
was DraftKings casino is bringing you
only the best Classics like Blackjack
roulette and Slots plus exclusive games
you won't find anywhere else Annie talk
to me oh the amount of time I've saved
having to go to Vegas it's to have Vegas
in bed while watching TV sitting next to
Randy and Todd it's a dream uh Todd
bringing me f it's I play Slots baby I
play Slots oh that's right you're a slot
I'm slots Todd plays poker I'm slots I'm
a blackjack girl all day black jack for
me it's too quick my money's gone I will
say the great thing about DraftKings too
is that if you're not ready to play with
real money like Annie you can do what I
do which is you know practice on all the
different games that they have on there
and you know get to know the games
before you put down the big bucks
download the DraftKings casino app now
and use code trash Tuesday new players
get an instant deposit match up to $100
in Casino credits when you deposit $5 or
more that's code trash Tuesday only on
DraftKings Casino the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit www.1 1800 gambler. net in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
president Connecticut Michigan New
Jersey Pennsylvania West Virginia only
void and Ontario eligibility and other
restrictions apply when per new customer
must opt in and make minimum $5 deposit
within 7 Days 168 hours of registering
new account Max match $100 in Casino
credits which require onetime
playthrough with 7 Days 168 hours C
terms at casino. draftkings.com new
player offer
[Music]
2024 I wanted to talk about so this this
jacket was given to me by a friend that
I friend dumped okay so it's been
sitting in my closet for 2 years and
today I was like I think we're past the
statute of limitations I just didn't
want to wear it because it was like The
Vibes of the Friendship were still on it
but now I thought it's time what do you
guys take on like if someone and it
could be like a boyfriend breakup or a
friend breakup I feel like if it's a
boyfriend I would not have as much a
problem if there wasn't any emotional
attachment to it but because it was a
friend breakup that to me is like that's
a little than a romantic breakup I think
some friend breakups hurt way yeah more
and for longer cuz you can't blame it
it's not like there was like a you can't
be like the sexual chemistry was off
there was more testosterone on this side
whatever and when you go through any
kind of breakup you know you're going to
be over it once you're on the new
relation but with a friend breakup you
don't get that yeah and I think usually
when I like do a friend breakup when
I've initiated them it hasn't been
because I'm like oh I need another
friend to fill that space it's just like
this actually is like not helping my
life and not it's actually like
triggering me making me feel not good
and move forward so it's not like I'm
like let's get rid of this one to
replace but in a romantic relationship
you are always even when you're trying
to stay single you are still like you
know Avail ex that's a specific role
that gets filled whereas friendship yeah
that that is a lot harder to get over
yeah I don't think I have any friend
item I don't think I've ever gotten a
gift from friend so that's not a um I
did recently um I still occasionally
wear like a piece of jewelry that um was
given by a guy who I saw for a couple
months and like this is going to sound
terrible but like when I look at it I
really just see how beautiful it is like
I don't think of that's good him at all
and I'm sure the purpose of the jewelry
was so that I could think of him but I
don't I just see how like I'm like this
is such a cool thing yeah and it was a
birthday gift and I'm like I'm going to
wear this forever are you having any
type of feelings about wearing the
jacket yeah when you put it on were you
like you know what I was thinking I was
like you know if she sees me wearing it
what's her feeling going to be but then
I'm like if she's still following me and
watching my stuff which I think she
might be that's like kind of on her it's
also done of your business yeah it's
only like how do you feel yeah and if
you but I think I would just I I just
felt like the reason I wasn't wearing it
wasn't because I had bad vibes about her
it just felt like it almost felt rude I
was the one that initiated it I almost
felt like rude to wear it yeah but I
think that it's okay for um to have long
lasting friendships and to have seasonal
friendships it's like everyone is sort
of like going in and out of different
parts of their life yeah when you're
healthy I think it's yeah and there are
people that I never had a bad ending
with but I just you know things just
phased out like we're no longer friends
and that's a that's fine for sure I know
I had to like aggressive it was like a
hard like I had to oh you had to clean
it was like over like it was not you
know sometimes it's like get the hint
ends and then then not get the hint ends
and wait have you guys heard of
this extremely
discounted clothing chain that only
sells in stores and not online called
Primark yeah yeah you have I have I
lived in London and it was like our the
biggest thing it's at my brother's mall
we always go to Primark wait can you
tell me okay so I had never heard of
this but then I started I got on to like
Forbes YouTube where they make all these
really like they like break down
businesses there's one like that was
like why sweet green still isn't
profitable it's the best video I've ever
watched um but then there's like the
business of Primark and I'm like I've
never heard of this so I watched this
whole video and it's really they're from
I think Ireland and they're in select
locations but their whole thing is like
you can only buy in stores so that
differentiates them
and it's it's like really affordable
it's almost like like twb shoes not even
kidding and it's cute stuff it's dirt
cheap and it is almost like if you could
go if you could buy like Sheen but you
could actually go and store and so I'm
like I was like drooling thirsting over
this place because the whole problem
with like Fast fashion amongst many many
things is that like if you order it
you'll get like one piece that's really
great and you're like I could have this
forever and then 10 other pieces that
are literally trash and two weeks later
it falls apart completely and they're
just disgusting like it's so hit or miss
so I'm like oh if you could only get it
in store so anyway so I I started
Googling Primark I found one I went over
winter break cuz they had one in the
suburbs of Chicago I think Woodfield
Mall this sweater the Primark Rita Aura
collection I was right what I said you
were Wednesday
Adams that Jenny Ortega oh that's Johnny
Ortega I was like I got it you know that
so close thank you you get it but you
guys $10 for a like how C I'm just my
mind is blown are you feeling like
because your clothes are I mean even
though you wear oversized clothes anyway
do you feel like you're going to wear
the clothes that you're wearing now when
you're not pregnant that is such a good
question I have no idea and I feel very
like I built up this whole closet and
then I got pregnant and everything is
irrelevant and then I have to build up a
whole pregnancy closet which is like not
that big of a closet but and then
afterwards it's going to be a whole new
thing like I just feel like maybe you'll
be like piecing the different ones
together cuz you do you were on an
oversized of course your oversized were
extra small on me but um but you were
oversized I do love an oversized
situation oversized is in though isn't
it like kind of a little bigger yeah
yeah I I don't know if I I I hope I go I
think you're going to be really oh who
knows who knows maybe you'll be making
up for all the food you didn't eat for
some reason I really identify as the
skinniest as pregnant woman to be born
and then I see myself on camera and I'm
like it's it's nice that I have that
confidence no you still look skinny you
still look skinny this is the same thing
as the age it's like you just look a
little heavier than you were before when
you were the skinniest you were the
skinny you were the skin you were very
very like not bad then you were like you
were at a very fit weight this is the
before you I know it's like a lot of
body talk whatever but when I got
pregnant I was like I was so my body was
banging before then I look at pictures
and I'm like my body was just fine like
it's I you always think well it's like
when you're now like doing this like
this thing that's in nature to for
another thing it's like if you were that
skinny and Pregnant like the baby would
be in full distress so it's like not it
wasn't like healthy for what you're
going through now you know but it I'm
like I look back and I didn't even look
good I look like weird I don't know I
just think that you've never not looked
good Esther no yeah you looked good
great like all versions of you like I
always just you're just even with this
white film on my lips thank you you look
um you still look Skinner than new girl
Esther how are you how is like life
treating you I was getting my nails done
I did um Edmonton um the comic strip
which is like inal did you ever do that
it's like the best mall it's like is
that the one with the DOL the Trap
Dolphins yes it's got the well it's not
Dolphins but it's Penguins they may have
had Dolphins at one point it's the best
you can do a meet gree with a penguin
there's it there's a full gym there's
nail salons I got
like it's just the hotel is a themed I
got a truck room it was crazy you guys
it was so funny the the bed was a was
the truck bed was like a you climb up
the truck and sleep on it I think those
are meant for a different kind of for
children little yeah little boys okay
well but there was a no of course um and
then there's a ceiling mirror so then I
was like oh [__] people are likeing in
here and then I looked to the right and
then there was like kids bunk beds I'm
like ew people are like their kids it's
so nasty but there's a big hot tub in it
in the room it's are you serious it's
the best I've never been here it's the
best it's the best they got me just a
regular room with just a hot tub in it
and I was so pissed I was like a hot tub
in the room yes they have like an an
igloo room they have an ice they was
that a mermaid room they have a mermaid
room they have a Polynesian room far
away is this Ed it's Edmonton's only
like it's not that long of a flight four
hours it's the best it's so fun wow and
and they have like a water park in there
they have a they have roller coasters
they have they did tell me they're used
to be a roller coaster and that they're
um I'm going to post a clip of me
talking to the audience about this but
someone got beheaded on it excuse me and
then and then they kept it going and
then look at the [__] pirate room and
then just because of cost they ended up
getting rid of it well I've always
wanted to and I still have never played
the comedy club that's in the Mall of
America it's the same thing it's
basically the same thing it's the same
owners but it's the one in the Mall of
America is basically the American
version of this Canadian one yeah it's
the best CU I grew up going to Mall of
America cuz my grandparents are in
Minnesota they live like 5 minutes from
it it's the best it's like a full
vacation so much fun we used to be Camp
Snoopy then Viacom bought it over now
it's like Nickelodeon land or whatever
but it's here's why I love Mall of
America the rides are not that scary I
know it's annoying but it's like they're
all manageable that would be so fun oh
my God could you trash Tuesday live at M
America I mean they're the it's
literally the most fun I was like I got
um when I went to the Mall of America
one it was like right after Co it was my
first weekend after Co um so you've done
that comedy club yeah I'm a mall [__]
if you think that there's if you think
there's a mall that I haven't performed
in you're crazy if there's a club in a
mall I've been there and there's no
sales tax on clothes in Minnesota yeah
well I didn't know that but I don't know
how much I was buying then but it was
like but I went I did like the I got
single like I got like the uzi pictures
like I went to the God I need you will
you be my Mall Runner I'm a mall what's
a mall Runner because I I think I
probably go to the mall I'm not kidding
it's not an exaggeration once every five
years it gives me a panic attack what
are you going for that's truly the most
unamerican thing you could ever say um I
just can't deal with the crowd the the
pressure of having to shop for like
Christmas presents and stuff like I I
did recently go to the Glendale Galleria
cuz I had to buy this one specific thing
that this one specific family member
wanted so and it was inside the it
wasn't outside at the Americana cuz the
outdoor shops are fine it's beautiful
yeah but the Glendale Gallery it's
actually gorgeous by the way where I
used to work there I used to work at the
abomi at the Glendale Galleria well I
think when you work at the mall you have
a different because I did work at Gap
Kids too but it's like you can't go
shopping is so stressful if you need to
get something yes yeah like just going
to the mall and being like all right I'm
going to be able to eat I'm going to be
able to what I need to do wander around
and so I think the key is to just go
with no purpose and maybe I can learn to
enjoy cuz I enjoyed it when I was young
that's where I get my IVs is at the mall
so I go to the mall a lot and then it's
like if I need something else I'm trying
not to shop as much but it's I had to
get skims what's your favorite Mall um
my favorite mall would be these malls
because they're crazy it's like I just
was thinking I was like is it worth it
to fly my nieces across country and then
into Canada to for them to be here
because it was just like going there
with your there's that ice skating ring
it's just like there's so much [__] it's
so fun I do like Mall food like the food
courts
I love a master walk Master walks I
never had master walk but I there um
always love a good Panda sesh just a
food court and there's no I'm sorry but
there's just no good food courts left
when you were teenagers that's true when
you were teenagers did you hang out at
the mall our high school was across the
street from the mall all the time that
was like it yes Old Orchard Mall the
first outdoor mall in the country not to
flex referenc to Mean Girls yes huge
deal and our food court is gone there's
a really good food court in a Korean
Plaza Mall here it is so good it's
mostly Korean food but it is you have so
many fun options so many fun like
dessert options and it's just like
really fun and pretty and kind of retro
I highly recommend I'll give you the
address I don't know if you guys have
ever been to an outlet recently but they
have the best food quartz it's literally
like it's from the '90s what makes them
different it's just back in it's like
they haven't changed sp sp Cinnabon jul
Orange juli
cabon Outlets has a fantastic when my
brother's friend worked at sabaro it was
so funny I was like what is Mike
Goldstein doing here like why are you
here right now you're [__]
embarrassing me can we get a couple more
qu of those questions also on Christmas
Eve we went to the movies at North bort
Mall which used to be like a great mall
in the suburbs but it has gone downhill
in a major way however they still have
an ant ANS is that a pretzel shop yeah
you have to ask I know she's being weird
let's pretend we didn't hear really
weird was that pick me what was that
what was she doing who is she playing to
right now I hated that okay so who is
she trying to impress we walk past the
ant ANS we just had our big Christmas
Eve wherever we went for oh wait can I
just um defend myself I only know Wetzel
Pretzel oh that's fair that's W West
yeah okay yeah okay when my credit card
got stolen they immediately went to
Wetzel Pretzel I was like that is so
funny I support I have never had someone
steal my credit and not go to places
that I'm like but a lot like wasn't
expens you're a queen you're a king or
queen you deserve it do you even like
dispute that charge then or you just let
them have that well they don't think
it's oh my God you guys my credit card
got shut off and they I had a call to
get it turned back on because I tried to
buy a book they said it was
suspicious that is so funny I was like
touche [__] touche but so we I have
not had an ant ANS in forever right cuz
that's just like it's too much it's
crazy they're so good it's a spiral it
just it doesn't lead to the next
decision being good you don't do one you
don't do one if you go to ant an or
you're doing a run so we walk past and I
thought I heard her say something the
woman working there I look at my family
and I look at I'm like did she just say
free pretzels they're like what this is
the saddest I this is going where I
think we went back and they're like yeah
every day at 5: when we're closed we
give away all the pretzels for free I
thought it was going to be that she did
not say free pretzels and you went to
get a free pretzel no so literally all
everyone in my family got a free pretzel
and we ate them like on top of our big
dinner and it was so disgusting but so
delicious and I couldn't control myself
and it was so good I got cinnamon sugar
flavor ask obviously I got cinnamon
sugar flavor but I'll take just The
Buttery ass ones I like the little
nuggets I like the little bites I was
regretting Che I'll get a cheese there's
not really a I used to love the the um
onion ones the they had I don't know if
they still have them but they had what
is the potato chip that's sour sour
cream and onion they had sour cream and
onion flavor y'all ever do the little
mini hot dogs oh a little mini hot dog
I'll take a little dog Todd loves a
little dog in a in a blanket but I my
nie I was facetimeing them from the mall
and I was like do you guys think about
me when you go to Auntie Ann's and
they're like No And I was
like my niece's I do have to say this is
a full Nightmare and this is my niece's
fault I was pandering to an 11-year-old
I got one to match her why is a
nightmare oh yeah I it's not it's a
nightmare it's spills all over my [__]
it's like there's no benefit to it it's
very heavy it's annoying it is huge
there's no can I hold that I wanted to
get like oh my God it's just why does
this exist I hate TRS I hate them why I
don't like it I think it's cool though
well you it's just really big it's the
worst bigger than your child it's
literally bigger than your child right
now it's a workout what's the pros of
that you look cool to an 11-year-old oh
okay for me my whole thing with it cuz
you know I would have been the first in
line to buy it but I'm like it's not
much I have so many Hydro flasks I went
through this I have the hydro flasks is
it the straw no there's nothing good
there is do you ever hold 18 things in
your hand at once I do that's why I had
to get a bigger purse cuz Todd's like
you and your things and then we're
always leaving and I'm like wait stop
here and I have to run back up I live up
the stairs so I have to run up the
stairs and grab like three more things
he's like I just I'm a thing [__] but
I'm trying to get rid of all my things
like I'm going through my house and I'm
like I can't like live like this anymore
have too many things I'm just throwing
out all my [__] I'm not worrying
about how much I paid for it it's over
it's done I just am decluttering because
it's like it's there's just too much
stuff there's too much stuff it feels so
good to get rid of stuff it's just why
am I making my life so difficult for no
reason it's like when I have like a big
house maybe I'll get more things but
it's like I'm like putting it all into
an apartment and we have reptiles now
it's like we got living things yeah
don't need all the other ones okay so
this question I mean divorce guys I'm
reading a had divorce analment an
immediately my husband didn't tell me he
had herpes until they got until we got
married thoughts on how I should feel
annulment he lied to you not telling you
something is the same as lying that's
pretty C you should be able to tell your
the person you're marrying also the the
crazy part is that like so many people
have this thing that's like who gives a
[__] I know like gen Z people they're
super upfront and open about any of
their steds herpes whatever and it's
like not a big deal right it's crazy
you're lying I had a friend who um I
mean they're married and they have like
kids now but um they like the beginning
stages of their relationship she got her
piece from him but she was just like
worth it I'm in love I'm not going to
like did he know he had herpes he
actually didn't he just sincerely didn't
he's like I've never really had like an
outbreak but she was like there's no
other person I could have gotten it from
so then they both got tested and he was
like oh [__] and he he was like but she
didn't give a so I think that this guy
like has it wrong the husband cuz I
think that if we love you like we're
fine there's Val TRS there's so many
other like I mean I can understand the
shame and being like afraid but that's
so crazy to not tell you before because
this is like second marriage type of guy
this is like crazy yeah it's also why
would you keep that from you get away
with that also like that's what I don't
understand about Herpes is it something
that
Li it you can be shedding it's like
really you can really get it when
there's absolutely no symptoms and stuff
and that's what kind of sucks the most
about it I think where it's not like you
that's where like but vrex is really
very works really well we're also
assuming this is like genital herpes and
not something like oh I have a cold SAR
because for the most part like most
obvious cold sores are herpes right so
it's like if it was that maybe I would
be like oh yeah like that's not
something shingles I got shingles when I
was 20 I don't think you need to
announce that but I did and but if it
was very like strategic on his end to
wait until after they were married
because he thought like that I feel like
is super deceitful and I would be so
bummed I just don't even know how you
pull that off cuz you don't people don't
you can it's it's very easy to pull off
it's very very easy because it's like if
you have your um outbreaks like under
control like the first sign of even
feeling some nerve pain here or some
nerve pain in your genitalia you can
take a vrex and valx works you almost
will not get is what they give to
reality show um people like dating show
PE contestants yeah so that there's no
outbreaks on set right I mean but it's
so it's so common it's so a nothing
thing like a Cav Val Trek that's that's
at your disposal so it's like especially
like years after your initial outbreak
you're not having as many outbreaks so
this I'm so sorry Julian you having that
in your back pocket to tell us is so
funny my producer friend told me it's
very interesting oh my God I am really I
am really confused by herpes too I don't
understand how it work like I'll give
you the breakdown after after okay I
yeah I know a lot about Herpes so if
someone is on Val TRX they can't pass it
on it's a lot harder to so it sounds
like herpes is actually not this crazy
serious thing that I feel like we all
thought it was when it just sucks so bad
my friends have had outbreaks and it's
like it's just so [__] painful it's
like they're and it's like in a place
where you have to like move and they're
open they can be open source like open
sores like it's like but if you can take
Val TR you never get it but when you
first get it and you don't know you have
it you have like and your first outbreak
is usually the worst yeah your first
outbreak and you're and you get like a
fever you get like sick yeah you your
lymph nodes are like inflamed and then
but like a especially if it's like I
think like her piece one is not as like
well I was told like not as like
outbreak heavy as like like herpes too I
think I don't know but my friend had
herpes my friend had herpes and she was
wouldn't tell guys and it was really
pissed me off cuz I thought it and this
was like I don't think she was on Val
truck set it was just like it just was
so dirty so she would like be flirting
with my friends and I'd be like just
heads up this is what you're getting
into and then it was always this thing
of like was I being shitty but but I'm
like no it's just not a deal breaker for
me if someone were to be honest and
upfront about it and say hey I have this
and there's ways around it and stuff
cool I have a girlfriend who has it and
she specifically like before hooking up
always would be like I have this which
is annoying it's annoying you have to do
it it sucks that does suck and it also
like her piece test is very separate
from a regular STD panel so like unless
you specifically ask CU it's a blood
test right so someone could be like oh
look STD like I'm I'm free I like I have
no chlamidia no gonorrhea HIV negative
whatever syphilis negative but the her
piece is not part of that um like STD
panel so you have to order it separately
so what I do with partners that I'm um
like going to sleep with is I will ask
for both so I will get like hey get SD
panel but also can you get checked for
this and it I do ask them for the extra
thing I can't believe you have to ask
for herpes that should really be on the
main menu the menu is there is there any
STD that like you don't need to like you
shouldn't you don't it's not necessary
to tell the pro yeah HPV because like
eight out of 10 people have it and also
men cannot test for HPV like there's no
unless get warts yeah unless they get
like warts or some type of like guys
when I got crabs I learned so much about
I used to call the SD hotline and like
hang out on the phone with them cuz I
was like didn't know there was one and I
learned so much about STDs they s they
would send me stuff in the mail I would
have all these like pamphlets and stuff
I learned so much and then when my
friend got her P I was so like I can
have compassion for the fact that it
sucks that she was in this position
where [__] but I was like it just was so
I felt so dirty I felt so torn as like a
human morally it was just like are you
serious just and it we lived in Santa Fe
it's such a small town I'm like you're
just like it's a small pool [__] so she
would hook up and not tell she would
without condoms yeah and then sometimes
if she felt like she wanted to date them
she'd be like I just got tested we have
herpes I feel like we need to deify it a
little
bit [__] up someone do that to my
brother though yeah he's gonna get maybe
but they like hooked up with him and
then I he called me he like oh my God
hooked up with this girl and she was
like it's not the sister-in-law that
watches the show so don't worry and she
told my brother like she like a day
later she got tested and she had herpes
which is like there's no way like the
day later you got tested you know one
time I had this rash these dots on my
stomach and I to the it was really weird
like I just and that was when I went to
the doctor for everything like I was
before I started Lexapro and it just
kind of let things go but like the
doctor was like let the pro and Let It
Go the or the dermatologist was like oh
this could be secondary syphilis and I
was like what people love to think
things are syphilis this is a thing and
I would I Google I'm like I have a
second round of syphilis that I missed
first round it was not that that's so
funny to me that they went straight
there people love to say things are
syphilis the rash is is um later more
it's like syphilis it's actually a sign
you're right not secondary but it's
later on in the progression of the
disease so it's like you missed the
whole first tier and didn't cure it and
then you get the new like the next step
I get rashes all the time that's so
crazy yeah no one's ever thinking oh
[__] this is syphilis I know but it is
syphilis is back on the rise people love
syphilis they love to diagnose she was
some like syphilis I always wondered why
people were named Phyllis like how long
has syphilis been around forever right
that's so funny that's a good nickname C
for some Phil come here s we used to
call Max pad my brother maxi pad I okay
so I had when I first started dating
Todd every time we would I would start
bleeding and people were like it's goria
it's Sy like everyone was like it's this
every time and of course Todd's like
that's right like boys are like blowing
that up but it was like oh my my God I
was like Jesus I don't know why this
happened what was it it was just a yeast
infection oh yeah it was just a yeast
infe but doctors like everyone's like
you better come in like my friends were
like why everyone I would talk to was
like this is something big this is a
horrible I'm like what I mean I got um
HPV when I was or I found out I had HPV
when I was 19 and I thought it was the
end of my life like I reacted like it
was the worst thing to have ever
happened to me I remember crying cuz
like at that time like no one really so
like young and sexually active too
you're like so like excited to meet
people and stuff and then you have like
they tell you that you have something I
know and then it was it just so happened
to be the strain that was a little bit
like sus so they had to like freeze my
cervix and it had to like sloth off for
like a month everyone I know lit the
thing where they like um they like take
like a some some kind of heat thing and
yeah that's what I had to do I literally
had a melt down Kila when that happened
I was like I'm I have cancer like it's
over like
is it if it's untreated or just one
because HPV they used to say like if you
have a very specific there's like two
specific types risk yeah the high risk
right that will could later progress
into like cancer or whatever so that's
why I got my stuff like frozen but I
remember thinking HPV that was like the
first STD and I was devastated she the
opposite of a fire crotch but it's like
a chill one because you can just get it
out right no I mean you don't even need
to do anything for most things not like
high risk yeah but I guess it was it
fell under some highrisk group but I
also I think back in the day they were
like they it's different like they've
had long they vaces now but they really
do go they went in and like Zapped like
it's the most painful experience I don't
know if it was for you yeah it was
terrible I remember going to we can
bleep his name out but I have to say his
name because it is a kind of a funny
name his name is Dr and Dr said that
this would not be painful um you're
going to not feel anything and I'm
telling you I was close to passing out
through the pain I was like and I
couldn't believe that like how dare this
man who doesn't have this body part of
mine tell me that something lie to me
and tell me something's not going to
hurt and then in Prime me open hurt me
in the way that he did and said okay
we're done you can walk away I was dizzy
lightheaded felt like I wanted to vomit
from the pain did did he num it or
anything or even if he he might have but
I don't remember anything but like utter
pain yeah my numbing thing didn't work
and it was the most painful I was
screaming in pain but it pisses me off
how like women's pains are like so
dismissed and it's like and they have
the tools to make it not hurt I know
they have it all they've got all back
there the vikin in the fent andol get it
out when I was um when I was 12 12 and
13 I had really really bad headaches I
just had like basically a headache every
day I was so bad and we went to this
headache specialist in Philadelphia
which was like so cool I was like oh
it's in my town where this like the top
headache specialist and we went and he
had this needle that was like this big
and he was like oh I'm just going to put
it in the back of your head to like see
what's going around like it won't hurt
and my mom was with me it was he's
stabbing the back of the neck okay he
was moving around he's like you have so
much Scar Tissue it was like crunching
you hear that Mom I'm screaming and
crying it was like the most painful
thing my mom was like so pissed my mom
was like we're never going back to this
person why did you have scar tissue in
your from a car accident wait really
yeah I was in a car accident when I was
12 that's why I stopped swimming it's
also shocking they don't talk about the
IUD like placement IUD placement is one
of the most painful pain and isn't it
painful for a while afterwards like
isn't it like for like a yeah and I
remember the woman was like well just
try having a baby sorry Esther but I was
like this is I was like this not right
no one talks about it I almost passed
out from pain well all your story and
every other girl's IUD story is like
identical and it's so crazy to me how
like they don't talk about it no it's
like women's pain is so just dismissed
and not heard it's a whole when I uh had
my miscarriage two years ago and I had
to get a DNC like the day before the
doctor asked me to come in so she could
put something in called a luminaria
which I was like what it's like some
weird like sponge that I guess they put
in there and like preps the cervix like
loosens it up whatever that
was horrible and the way that they were
so casual about just come on in I'm like
you didn't tell me I would have I should
have been on something like it was so
yes it's quick but it's like you don't
want to be it's also such like a like a
rough time too it's like you're going to
just add like and then they say like
you're okay not like prepare you yeah
although I did have one of the best
doctors at Planned Parenthood when I
terminated a pregnancy like the sweetest
man ever I thought that I the drugs were
available and I did not take them
because I had to drive myself home and
so I was like oh I don't want to be kind
of like sedated driving home and so I
was like I'm going to opt out of the
drugs and he was like ooh are you sure
and I was like yeah I'm sure like and he
goes well it's really only a minute he
was very specific it's going to be a
minute and a half of this specific type
of pain he like he like really explained
it well and he counted down you had a
DNC without drugs or being yeah what
just like do not recommend it and then I
told the girl who was like next to me
before I went in I was like she was like
do you think I should take the I was
like no no need I mean it's such a short
procedure and I felt so bad cuz I saw
her getting like wheeled out after and
she was like in shock I'm like God when
you give people the wrong advice
her take the medication because that's
like a full procedure where I was out I
was put under for that yeah but it's
really only a minute right because and I
was awake for the whole thing and he
counted me down he was so sweet he goes
this is what you're going to feel right
now and it was so specific so it
prepared I was able to like prepare my
senses for it and I was like this man is
the sweetest this is how doctor should
be it's like you should he's like you're
supposed to take the drugs but if you
don't this is the kind of pain you he
wasn't lying it Su yeah oh my God never
again don't get abortions um raw my my
exactly where it raw dog wear your
sponge yeah don't raw dog your abortions
guys it really really hurts and maybe
don't raw dog and you might not need
them so I think the lesson is no more
raw doging let's take it a step further
yeah no more raw dogging unless you're
on is all about the prophylaxis the
preventative medicine
propis do we know if vasectomies hurt
you know we'll never know cuz men are
like always being like doed on and given
all the right drugs never God little
babies these little babies but you know
what Julian's like what about the men
Julian we need you we might need to hear
more about uh the reality show
valre he was so excited to tell us that
it was just so cute you just been
waiting he has little notes like that
that he likes to sh but you know what to
that I say bring back raw
vasectomies let's try it out I want
nothing raw ever again in life not even
Sushi like I'm so traumatized by the
word raw right now the fact that you had
a raw abortion is like absolutely most
psychotic thing I've ever learned about
a person and Shout Out Planned
Parenthood they do great things PP baby
it's like if I had to drive myself home
be like okay I'm sleeping over tonight
at Planned Parenthood I'm that's fine
I'm getting the drugs by the way my
sister was at home making my abortion
porridge and she was like please let me
drive you back home and I was like I'll
be fine do you think you were feeling
like guilty that you had to do it or
something you were like punishing
yourself um maybe and or maybe I was
just in a state of like I just got to
get this done yeah just like don't even
think about it and Bobby was
asleep yeah and also it wasn't my
sister's job to be there for me like she
has a regular job she had things and
Bobby was not there could not be there
he soften you up you're too tough I I'm
not anymore she said that earlier right
it's funny cuz you just said that
earlier in the episode you were saying
you're going to stop being like I'm the
tough person oh yeah I'm not tough like
everything hurts me let's soften her
well it's just the faking that things
don't hurt I have that too it's like
they're just like oh I'm so hearty it's
like yeah I'm not is it more Brave to be
like vulnerable until tell the yeah it's
Brave to be weak I said vulnerable not
weak it's Brave to be scared like it's
just but I do like being scared I do
like it oh yeah you're like a if if a
roller
coaster doesn't have the potential to
like kill someone or behead someone like
you're not interested I was excited when
they said the beheading got a little
excited I was like that would have been
not great to see but not not a
memory not not a memory um all right
guys what a fun week I know we have a
there's a lot of feelings in today's I
I'm feeling so many things we got
through um STDs we've tackled lot of
vaginal talk a lot of vaginal talk
vaginal talk we needed it we were do we
were do don't say do don't you're right
mucus plug we're never saying that again
don't say that three
times um not cork we will see you guys
thank you so much we'll see you next
week with a brand new episode and don't
forget to get tickets to our live trash
Tuesday in Los Angeles Regent Theater
February 13th have gallentine day with
us it's going to be crazy we'll see you
there and see you next
[Music]
week
w